والده بلال لا تعرف بوفاته وارقام رونالدو
تنهال على النصر وميسي يشكر جماهير
برشلونه هذه الاخبار وغيرها نقدمها لكم من
العربي رياضه اهلا بكم
قالت شقيقه اسطوره كره القدم البرازيليه
الراحل بيليه ماريا لوسيا ان والدتها
البالغه من العمر 100 عام لا تعرف حتى
الان بوفاه ابنها بيليه ومن المفترض ان
تمر جنازه الكلاب بمنزل والدته يوم
الثلاثاء المقبل في واحده ستكون من اطول
الجنازات في التاريخ وكان بيليه قد نشر
بوست على انستغرام قبل سبعه اسابيع احتفل
من خلاله ببلوغ والدته مئه عام وتدعى دون
سيلستيه وعلق بلالين من صغرها علمتني كلمه
الحب والسلام لدي اكثر من 100 سبب لاكون
ممتنا لكونها امي
اما الظروف الصحيه فاتمنع اسطوره كره
القدم الالمانيه
من حضور جنازه زميله السابق بالله وقال
بتمباز صحيفه بلد الالمانيه اود حضور
الجنازه ولكن لسوء الحظ صحه لا تسمح لي
بالسفر لمده طويله سارفق صديقي في قلبي في
رحلته الاخيره ولعب باليه الى جانبه بيكنج
باور في نيويورك
من القرن الماضي
جمع نادي النصر مليونير ريال سعودي في اقل
من 24 ساعه نظيره بياع كم كريستيانو
رونالدو في متجر الفريق الرسمي اذ نفذت
الكميه مع بيع اكثر من 5000 قميص يحمل
الرقم سبعه وكان متابعون بالنصر على
انستغرام زاد عددهم من 700000 الى خمسه
ملايين و600,000 متابع منذ الاعلامي عن
الصفقه
في رساله او في رساله وداعيه للعام 2022
شكر النجم الارجنتيني ليونيل ميسي جماهير
نادي السابق وصانع امجاده برشلونه
الاسباني
لما انا فيه من دونكم ومن دون جماهير التي
تتابعني وتحبني من كل انحاء العالم